foreign
today we will take you through a hands
of lab demo of prediction of FIFA World
Cup Qatar 2022 using machine learning
before we start I hope this screen is
clearly visible and the audio is fine if
yes please type in yes if there are any
issues do let us know in the chat
section so that we can resolve them
I'm repeating again before we start I
hope this screen is clearly visible and
the audio is fine if yes please type in
yes if there are any issues do let us
know in the chat section so that we can
resolve them
let's wait for some more minutes to let
other people join
until then let me tell you guys that we
have regular updates on multiple
Technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
I'm repeating again let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
Technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
great I think we can get started in
today's session we will go through some
different questions regarding football
and solve them using different
functional libraries of python and at
the end we will predict the winner of
FIFA World Cup Qatar 2022
so here is one question for you guys
which team will win the Qatar 2022 FIFA
World Cup
or you can comment down your favorite
team in the FIFA okay so let's move to
the programming part
so first we will open command prompt
to write command to open Jupiter
notebook okay
here I will write Jupiter
notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and here I will select new
python kernel file
so this is how the Jupiter kernel looks
like so here first I will rename
FIFA
Qatar
prediction
okay
first we will import some major
libraries of python which will help us
in analyzing the data
so for that I will write here
import
date time
okay
then import
numpy as NB
then import
pandas as PD
then import matplotlib
dot Pi plot
as PLT
okay import
C bone
T-Bone sorry C bone as
SNS
then import
warnings
okay then warnings
dot filter
warnings
yes ignore
then press enter
yeah
so numpy number is a python Library used
for working with arrays it also has the
function for working in the domain of
linear algebra and matrices
it is an open source project and you can
use it freely numpy stands for numerical
python
pandas pandas is a software Library
written for the Python programming
language for data manipulation and
Analysis in particular it offers data
structure and operations for
manipulating numerical tables and Time
series
seabon
an open source python Library based on
matplotlib is called C bone it is
utilized for data exploration this one
data exploration
and visualization
with data frames and the path pandas
Library c bond function with ease
matplotlib for Python and its numerical
extension numpy mat.lib is a closed
platform data visualization and
graphical charting package as a result
it presents a strong open source
substitute for Matlab the apis for
matplotlib allow programmers to
incorporate graphs into GUI applications
this date time
this Library
one of the most often used module to
modify date and time object data in
Python
this is the built-in Library
in addition to creating date and date
time objects you can read and convert
data strings iterate across a range of
dates and more so moving forward let's
import our data set okay so for that we
will write here DF equals to PD dot read
underscore CSE
okay
then here International
a school matches
my data set name dot CSE
okay here I will write DF dot hat
press enter yeah
so here PD is for pandas Library read is
used for reading the data set from the
machine and CSV is used for the type of
file which we want to read
okay so if you want top five rows okay
one two three four five if you want top
five rows of your data set you can use
head and if you want last five rows of
your data set you can use till instead
of head
and this data set International
underscore matches
you can download this data set from the
description box below okay so moving
forward let's check how many rows and
columns are present in our data set so
for that
I will write here
DF dot shape
okay press enter
so here as you can see
23921 underscore
comma 25 okay
so here 23921 means rows number of rows
are present in our data set and 25
columns
okay
so moving forward let's see what the
data type of the columns and non-null
values count by using info function
so here I will write DF dot info
okay then press enter
the data frame information is printed
via the info method the data includes
the total number of columns their labels
date kinds memory use range index and
the number of cells in each column like
non-null values
note that the info method does not
indeed print the information
got it so
here
we have 24 25 columns with non-null
count is
this much and data type is like some are
of object sum of integer and Boolean
type float type okay
so moving forward
exchange date to format date using date
time Library okay for that I have to
write here pf8
equals to PD Dot
to underscore date time
then DF
then
date
okay
then here you have to write DF then
press enter
yeah
so everything seems cool
one of the most often used modules to
modify date and time object is in Python
is the built-in function date time
library in addition to creating date and
date time objects you can read and
convert date strings I trade across a
range of dates and more
okay
so moving forward let's reshape this
data
okay
so for that
let me make a good view
yeah
it is fine I guess
so for this I have to write FIFA
underscore rank
equals to
GF
8
form underscore team
comma
away underscore team
comma
oh
let's go d
underscore FIFA
underscore rank
okay
and then
comma
then you have to write away underscore
team underscore FIFA
underscore rank
okay
then again comma
then you have to write here away
underscore team
underscore
total
underscore FIFA points
okay
then one more
underscore team
underscore
total
underscore FIFA underscore points
better than
home
equals to FIFA underscore rank
then
date
comma
home team
comma
home
team underscore FIFA rank
people underscore rank
then
home underscore team underscore
total
underscore rank
not rank here points
okay
then dot rename
columns
equals to
so here we are just renaming the column
or you can say reshaping the data
so here I'm built right home underscore
data
sorry team
with
only team
okay
comma
oh then here I will add home underscore
team underscore FIFA
underscore rank
with rank
comma
here I will write
home
underscore
team underscore total
FIFA
points
okay
and underscore rank
s
press enter
then you you have to date a way
equals to
FIFA underscore rank
and
let me just copy from here
so here I will just remove this to away
team
here away
dot rename
the name then same
copy it from here
to here
foreign
so what I will do I will just change to
away
like instead of home I will write away
let's enter
yeah
so then FIFA
FIFA underscore rank
question oh
dot append
then up
so we will select for each country is
the latest match so for that I have to
write FIFA underscore rank
equals to
FIFA underscore and
dot sort
values
team
comma date
what
sending
equals to
true
then FIFA underscore
rank
go underscore
number
FIFA
underscore
rank dot Group by
team
Dot
com count
plus one
okay and FIFA
rank underscore top
equals to FIFA
underscore
rank
then FIFA
rank
and
we'll write row number
what's equals to one
dot drop
then row underscore number
comma comma X is equals to 1
then
Dot and smallest
and
comma
okay so let's see
FIFA underscore
rank underscore top
then press enter
or might be there will be error
okay away team total FIFA points
yeah so now it's working so now let's do
Eda exploratory data analysis but before
that we have to check some null values
okay
so here like we will list all the
columns which contain an N values so for
that we have to write here columns
contains
null values
okay equals to
column and column
okay for column in
DF dot columns
if
DF
d f call
dot is null
dot any
then print
columns contain
values
okay
the instruction the installation
and columns
columns contains
null
okay then press enter
okay
yeah so these are the columns which
contains
and then values
so
now I will write
World Cup 2022
equals to
all the countries name which are playing
okay so starting from Qatar
then
Twitter
or
he could
then single
the lens
USA
is
mama
Argentina
Saudi Arabia
Mexico
yeah
uh Mexico then then
I can write Poland
then
trans
Australia
come on
Saudi Arabia
Denmark
come on
comma
Spain
come on
then Costa Rica
Germany
Japan
lgm
yeah come on
then I will write here
Canada
then Croatia
okay
then Brazil so I'm writing group wise
Serbia
Switzerland
give me wrong
maroon sorry
and this Portugal
then
gonna
Uruguay
Korea
Republic
then press enter
yeah
so these all are the countries which are
playing World Cup 2022 FIFA World Cup
so I will write one function here
like for
X in World Cup 2022
10 for y and
columns
contains
null
then d f y
dot Bill any
then DF
DF again then y
o issue
ratio 9
.
then equals equals to X
why mean dot mean
in place
equals to
true
okay
then
okay this is fun added
the series
in place it is sorry
so
everything seems cool
so we will now start with the questions
take a different different questions so
the question number one is is there any
home team Advantage okay
so let me write here
is there any home
team
advantage
okay so we will not deep dive into
theories and all so we will code
and let's see
so here I will write
home team
question
DF
entry
okay
just move this
G comma
home
underscore team underscore
and
away
team
score
okay
then I will write here home
underscore team Dot add
press enter
team score is not an index
so these are some teams and other team
scores
we will check for all the times home
team won their games for that after at
home
team
score
is greater than
home team
away
team score
okay
then home underscore wins
equals to
home
team
Dot
Loc
team
like
team score
a home team
away
team
underscore scope
yeah so let's see
team is not defined
underscore wins
is not defined by
okay
so here you can see when the home team
wins okay like home team won their games
like three one five zero one zero four
zero blah blah blah yeah
so
now what we will do we will check for
all the times home team lost their games
not when lost their games so I will
write home team
that can home
team score
home team
away
team
score
then home underscore loss
question
home team
Dot
log
like
team
okay home
team
underscore score
and
home team
away
team
score
then home
underscore loss okay then press enter
yeah
so these all are the
matches which are like
they lost their games okay home team
lost their games
one three zero one zero seven zero one
one two
okay
so
like moving forward we will merge this
like both the tables this this one this
table and this table okay
so for merging I have to write here
home underscore at
question home wins
and Country
comma
home team
underscore score
then
the
way
team
score
Dot rename
columns
equals to
home team
core
with
home team
win
okay then
comma
and here I will write
I have to write here away
team
score
underscore team
loss
okay
then press enter
and what I will do like I will copy this
will copy this
this one
and paste it here
okay
then there are some minor changes
yeah
so
after this
I have to write Home Advantage
it was soon home
underscore ad dot append append is used
for merging
then away
advantage
okay
and let me print
home
advantage
dot add
data frame dot rename got an extra
columns okay it's
okay
yeah
so we must both the table
okay so at the end we will see visual
representation of the home team
advantage
okay
so for that I have to write home
underscore advantage
dot mean
then Dot Plot
find
equals to Pi
and comma
Titan
equals to
home
advantage
versus
home
team loss
okay
on team loss
and labels should be
team wins
comma
home team loss
yeah
then bigger size should be
X comma six
they are PLT Dot Legend
press enter yeah
so here you can see the graphical
representation of home team Advantage
versus home team loss okay so there is
you can see slightly advantage of home
team if you are a home team
rather than home team loss okay
so question first was is there any
advantage of home team yes
you can say as per the data set yes
there might be a chance of home team
Advantage okay home team wins
let me do like this for the better
visuals yeah
so the question number two is which team
has the more wins
okay which team has the most wins
so here we will create a new data frame
so let me write the question first
which team has the most wins
okay
so here I will write home underscore
team
equals to DF
date comma
home team
comma
home team let's go to score
comma away
underscore team underscore
then I will write here home
underscore team dot hat
foreign
so moving forward what I will do
I will check for all the home team that
won their games
okay
all the home deals that want their games
so for that home team
score
it's greater than home
team
with team score
okay then home
pins
to home
team underscore
Dot Lock then
home team
home underscore team underscore score
then
the home team
away
underscore team underscore score
and let me print home
wins
dot hat
okay Center
a moments
so like we have home team that won their
games
okay
so moving forward we will see like away
team won their games okay
for that like home
team or basically you can say home team
which lost their games nothing else
home
team score
team
way
score
okay home loss
equals to
home team
underscore
sorry Dot Lock
then
Android home underscore team
and again home
team score
team
then away
team score
yes
enter let's see
homeless dot head
so here you can see
like away team which won their games or
you can say home team which lost their
games okay
so moving forward we will merge this
both the tables so for that it's so easy
so let me copy from here
to close from here
paste it here
so I will do here certain changes
like home team
okay then
against country
so then country I will write here date
home team
home team score away team score
team
and
home demisco
okay for that I will write here boom
team
score home team win
then waiting score
have a team pin
waiting when
okay
here also away team win
and also I will add one more
okay
okay
yes
it
comma
so let's see
so here I will add
with team
okay so I'll let team
underscore streak
equals to home team
pins
dot append
away
team pins
okay then
team streak
press enter
okay invalid syntax where as
a
name column
that is just s
team score home team win
our team score every team win
or rename column
columns
okay let me what can I do is
copy it again and
yes yeah
so it's working fine
okay
so
like
we have mercy table away team and home
team wins
so now let's check
most win by the countries
okay so for that I will add team
underscore streak
team
dot value
counts
or largest
one
so
USA is the country which has won the
maximum matches
so this team has the most wins
the answer is USA as per the data set
okay
so moving to the third question
so the question is
just let me do it like this
what is the winning percentage comparing
when the highest ranked team plays
against the lowest ranked team
okay so let me write it again here
what
is the
winning
percentage
percentage
comparing
when
yes
Bank
team
plays
against
West
Rand team
okay
so for that we have to write DF victory
team one comma team two
comma t
one underscore
rank
comma team two underscore
comma team
one underscore score
Obama
team
to underscore score
so if
team one
underscore score
is
team two
underscore score
inner
equals to T1
okay
then
alif
lcf or alif
EM1
underscore score
team two underscore score
just making a
situation winner
also drawn
this course
a level
Okay match will be draw
else
you know
soon team two
then return
so here I will write DF
plus two
DF Dot
apply
Lambda
X
victory
then X
home underscore team
comma X
waiting
comma
X
team
FIFA
rank
okay
waiting
FIFA
tank
foreign
score
team
score
from my Axis equals to 1.
so here I will create one more function
t f rank
home comma away
comma
rank ohm comma
rank
okay
then if
rank home
rank
okay
return
home
else
done
away
and
I will write
here
DF
like better drank
better underscore rank
equals to DF dot apply
Lambda
X
rank
home underscore team
comma X
away
team
come on
X
4
Team FIFA rank
FIFA underscore rank
okay
then I will write X
away
the
FIFA underscore rank
then axis
equals to one
then
they have result
tank
inner comma
better run
if winner equals to equal to
drawn
and return
winner
if
winner equals equals to better rank
and
return
else return
more list
okay
it is a smallest
so DF
result
underscore rank
okay
DF
result
rank
so DF
dot apply
Lambda
Lambda
X colon result
let's go
rank
in a
comma X
better
comma
access goes to 1.
was 2.
so
at the end let me plot the graph
and the answer you can say PLT dot
figure
size
pursue
n comma 5
total
equals to
load
ax equals to
sns.count plot
question result
underscore rank
comma data underscore DF
might be I can write equals to DF
so for p n
x dot patches
percentage
pursue
colon
dot one F like 10 one decimal
okay
or if I'll write 2 here it means two
decimal points
okay and
percent
dot format
rate
into
P dot get
right
okay wait
goes to P Dot
get
let's go with
right equals to P Dot
get
okay
X comma
y equals 2
e dot get
X Y both
then ax Dot
annotate
percentage
comma X
Plus
with Slash by 2
comma
y Plus
height
into
1.02
comma H equals to
n Center
okay
then I will write here PLT dot show
and press enter yes
a smaller size
where is the drawn one
it's strong
colon
oh okay
this is one
two three ten
team away team home team FIFA Rank and
awaiting FIFA rank okay fine
and result rank winner a better rank
then drawn
return winner
okay okay let me check
yeah
so now it's coming there is one mistake
of spelling okay
so our question was what is the winning
percentage comparing when the highest
ranked team plays against the lowest
ranked team okay highest ranked team
plays against the lowest ranked team
so
the answer is this
okay chances are highest is like 54.9
percent so when and drone is like 23.9
and losing is like 20 21.2
okay
so
moving forward
now we will see what is the winning
percentage comparing when the highest
attack rank plays against the lowest
attack ranks
okay
what is the winning percentage comparing
when the highest attack
plays against the lowest attacking rate
okay so let me write here
what is
the percentage
comparing
when
the
highest
attack
rank
place
with
the lowest
attack
okay
question is clear I guess
so let's solve this TF rank attack
equals to DF
om t
ense
School
Dot not null
okay
then DF
rank
attack
goes to DF
DF
away
t
mean
and
underscore score
kernel
this should be one square bracket yeah
press enter
now I will create one function
rank attack
like home
comma away comma
rancome
okay
then we will write if
rank
home
is greater than
rank away
return home
else
return
away
and DF rank
attack
is
like better
underscore attack
was to
DF dot apply
Lambda
X
mdax rank attack
s
like home team home underscore team
comma X
away
team
comma X
and here I will write a home team
mean
oh
right here
X
[Music]
away
team mean
hence
score
just
one
yeah there is one error
rank attack this okay spelling mistake
there's one more error
but
that's the typing is mistake so no
issues
so after this I will write here DF
rank
attack
result
soon DF underscore
rank underscore
attack
Dot apply
apply
amda
result
let's go rank
you know
come
better
attack
axis
was to one
okay
so let's see the results the final
output of this question PLT dot figure
and figure size
equals to
and comma 5
total
equals to
load
EF underscore rank
let's go attack
x equals to SNS
dot count plot
equals to result
underscore
attack
go to right here
comma data equals to
DF
back
then for p
in ax dot patches
and percentage
oh this is the same one so I can copy it
okay let me copy it
here
so here you can see let's read the
question first
what is the percentage comparing when
the highest attack rank plays with the
lowest attack rank okay so highest
chances like to win is 43 drawn charges
23.9 and the smallest chance is 32.9
okay
so moving to the next question
so now what we will do
like we will find
the best ratio of goals versus offensive
score
okay best ratio of course versus offense
ratio or
or what
what you can say is like
who teams with a stronger offensive
player score more goals and do with
stronger goalkeepers receive fewer goals
I'm writing here
to teams
with stronger
expensive
players
or
more goals
and
two
teams with
longer
goalkeeper
Steve
viewer goals
okay
so the question is this
I hope the question is like clear to you
okay
so
now
let me write
here
offense
underscore score
soon
sorry
for X in
two zero two two
expensive score
NP Dot
round
e f then DF again
then
on team
what's equals to
X
what can I do is not copy
okay
X
then
again
home team
Cisco
dot mean
this DF
then DF
then waiting
a team
equals equals to X
okay team
oh
I don't mean
like there's two
comma 2.
so here I have to write
the score score
dot append
and safe School
friends
underscore scores
PD Dot
data frame
team
world cup two zero two two
comma
foreign
values
of score
comma ascending
equals to
false
okay comma
reset
index
drop
also true
desert index
uh question true
and here
of ants underscore scores
Dot
index
plus one
equals to
you can write plus equals one
then offense
let's go to scores
then drop
question
true
aof score
your fans scores
is not callable
I just go data frame dot to fscore
check
Cisco
s dot sort values
of score ascending fals is at index
tropical citro
the mirror here
it's
tested
M object it is not callable
score
so what we can do here is we can remove
this
and try to yeah so it's working now
so moving forward like we will see the
goals scored like away team and total
goal is scored by Steam and conceited
goal at home considered goal at away
total considered goals like this
so for that like it's a long quote so
let me copy it from my
Myspace to like this so let me copy it
here and paste it here yeah
so let's see the graph so
from this here you can see we have now
scored goals home
uh goal is code like away a total is
goals scored and conceited goals away
home and total and goal difference
between considered goal and the total
goal
and this goal issue now we have mostly
everything
so
what we will do now we will see offense
strength versus goal scored okay
so
for this let me copy it yeah
so here you can see
total scored goals versus total scored
goals versus GK scores like Top Notch
goalkeeper schools okay
so moving forward let's plot this graph
like you will be having clear
understanding after that
so PLT dot figure
bigger size
question
11 comma seven
comma DPI
assume 90
then ax
equals to SNS dot bar plot
and data
equals to
offense
players
versus
goal
okay
then we will take top 10 only
okay X
equals to
team
of y equals to
total
scored
goals
this is
goalkeeper
score
so ax dot bar label
the x dot
containers
is zero
PLT dot X label
with team
PLT dot y label
because
ratio
than
PLT dot title
is
top
10 best team
issue
of goals
and offense
score
okay
then press enter
offense players versus
players versus
goals
scored should be goals
could not interpret into total sport
goals
GK goals
score goals
versus G K goals
x dot containers
containers
yeah
so here you can see top 10 best team
ratio goals versus offense ratio so as
Brazil Mexico Germany Japan USA Spain
Korea Republic Netherlands Australia and
Portugal so here are the ratios written
on the top of the containers every
containers
okay
so now we will see top 10 teams best
ratio considered goals versus GK scores
okay
this was goals versus offense score
now we will see
top 10 teams best ratio considered goals
versus GK score
so
like every will everyone will do the
same
so let me copy it and paste it for you
let me run this
quickly so we can move ahead
with the next question
so here you can see
I have like goalkeeper versus gold
considered ratio like
okay this is goalkeeper score
and this is total considered goals and
this is the ratio of the particular one
okay
these are the teams and the GK scores
for the particular goalkeeper
okay
let me run this
yeah top 10 best team ratio considered
goals versus GK score okay Serbia Spain
France Morocco Portugal Netherland
Brazil Canada Australian Wales
okay
so moving forward we will see top 10
teams with the longest win streak
so I'm writing here
the question
top
10 team with the
longest
win streak or you can write like this
team has the longest winning streak okay
or that
to write here so this is the long one so
let me copy it
and paste it here
yeah
okay this is saying all errors must be
of the same length
okay
streak streaks
oh
20th line
yeah this one sticks because so PD dot
data frame
team
streaks
what value streak ascending false
that should be index
okay let me find the error
so now let's write code for the
graph so we will write
PLT dot figure
that there's size
two
11 comma seven
then comma API
equals to 90.
also SNS
dot bar plot
then data
also streaks
and
equal to
team
streak
okay then x dot bar
underscore label
ax dot containers
and
PLT Dot
X label
should be team
LT dot y label
should be strict
okay
and PLT dot title
of
10 teams with
longest
streak okay
so press enter
according to play the streak okay as
should be capital
I guess
okay
yeah
so here you can see the top 10 teams is
the longest winning streak uh like Spain
is the longest win yesterday 12 with 25
and then France Brazil Australia Belgium
Morocco Saudi Arabia and so on
okay
so the next question is like better team
win percentage in home team and other
team okay
so for that
so I'm repeating again the next question
is better team win percentage in home
team and away team
okay
so for that
uh I will write here question but uh
team
win
percentage
team
with team
okay
so let's write code for this away team
underscore better underscore rank
equals to DF
f
AME
FIFA
rank
foreign
value
counts
away
team
better
Center
so this is the away team better rank
like lose and when s3429 and the choice
2840 okay
so same with the home team better rank
so I will just copy it
and this is same like this
and press enter
so the home team better rank is 8313 and
2542 is draw and losing is one seven
eight one
so let's see the win percentage so for
that I will copy it here and yeah so
home win percentage is
65.79 okay and the away win percentage
is 44.29 if you play against
like not in your country okay the total
is 55.566
so let me
make it
in a graph so PLT dot figure
okay
size
equals to
11 comma
seven
comma DPI
equals to
90
ax equals to
sns.bar plot
data
was true better
team
event person
yeah
it's equals to better
team
then
percent
dot index
y equals to
percent
okay so ax dot bar
underscore label
x dot
containers
and zero
okay PLT dot X label is
e better
than PLT dot y label
is
10 percent
PLT dot title
let's go
better
team win person
okay
then press enter
so as you can see the home team win
percentage is 65.79 which is the highest
and the other team is 44 and the total
is 55. okay
so moving forward
we will see
the best goalkeeper score okay
which countries having best goalkeeper
score like best rate defense best
offense and best Midfield
and after that we will see the like top
15 countries which
can be win okay
so for that
so
here
now we will see like
I will write the question
best
uh
defect offense
and
goalkeeper
and goalkeeper
which contains goalkeeper
okay
these are the ranks of the particular
team okay
based on the like
Like Home Team FIFA ranking okay just a
FIFA ranking okay
so moving forward
like we will check the best goalkeeper
score so for that I will write goal
goalkeeper
score score
X in
GK
GK underscore
question NP Dot
round
DF stand
DF again then
um
team
equals to go to x
team
goalkeeper
score
dot mean
okay so here
plus DF
f
away
team
plus equals to X
away
team
keeper
team goalkeeper should be goalkeeper
score
but mean
S2
comma 2.
right here
goal
people
underscore
goalkeeper
underscore
score Dot
append
GK school
and
I will
copy it
and
let's go meet
list objects is not append
spelling mistake yeah so as you can see
here we have the all the
goalkeeper score
of the particular company
so we will what we will do not we will
make a figure a graph you can see
so PLT dot figure
size
so what I can do I can copy it from here
okay
and we will change the particular things
the data is from
will keep our scores
and column 15 okay I will give 10 take
10.
then x equals to team
let's see
let's go
team
y label should be score
they should be
you know stop
then
goalkeeper let's go
alkeeper scores
in
non-interpret GK score
where's the GK score
as you can see here top 10 goalkeeper
score like
Spain is having top goalkeeper score of
83.06
so moving forward we will see
the same for the defenses code attacks
true strength and Midfield strength
same as fin okay
what I will do I will just copy it and
paste it here and
so these are all the defensive score
okay calculating from Team home team
defense score okay as per the other team
away matches
so this is the defensive score
top 10.
this is the top 10 defense school like
Spain is having the most 80.64 than
Serbia England and Germany and so on
okay now let's move forward and see the
rate of attack best rate of attack
okay
best rate of attack
so this is the attack strength in a
tabular manner so we will plot a graph
for this so
we'll go at 10
that [ __ ]
this is the top 10 attack score most
Argentina is having most 83.51
following by Spain 82.41 then so on till
Belgium
okay
and same with the Midfield score
will score
if I am copy pasting it because it is
the similar code
throughout
for all the values okay now let's see
for the top five only
Spain France Germany England Argentina
okay
so
now we will see the win percentage
okay like top teams with the highest win
percentage like they can be winning this
FIFA World Cup
okay
so for that I have the code
so here you can see I have just
background color green for the
particular
thing like home win and win percentage
okay so here you can see uh like Brazil
total is four three three and three zero
one is Win 76 raw 56 lose and from this
winning from this 301 181 is the home
win which is the biggest advantage okay
then we will see for the all
equator whales Belgium Croatia Germany
you can see the win percentage
is having Brazil is having the highest
okay
so what we will do now we will plot a
graph for this
or that
we'll write the code PLT dot figure
then because size
was to
11 comma seven
okay and then DBI is same
then
x equals to
SNS dot bar plot
then data equals to when
draw
underscore lose
will show this time top 15
comma
X is equals to
team
y question
percent
PLT dot X label should be
team
and PLT dot y label should be
so
then PLT Dot
title
15
teams with highest
win percentage
so what I can do
I will take this containers part
and put it here
okay let's send
okay W is capital here
yeah
so here you can see top 15 teams with
the highest win percentage like Brazil
France Brazil zayas
69.52 then 69.49 in Spain France Germany
Iran till Morocco Belgium Australia
Mexico
okay
so
here I will write some
code related to columns
so
here DF
is born
so DF
score
difference
okay
this DF
is
stake
pursue DF
tournament
was you
friendly
press enter
invalid syntax is found
okay okay sorry forget to write 0 here
yeah
so let me check once okay there is one
more score difference
good let me check the columns
yeah home team away team home content
continent home team FIFA rank till stick
okay
now we will do the main part we will
predict who will win the
the FIFA World Cup 2022 Qatar
okay
so now import some major libraries for
the model evaluation and the testing and
training the data so I will write from
sqlarn
import
linear
underscore model
okay from sqln
code
and symbol
from Escalon
dot model
underscore selection
import
train
underscore
just underscore split
Skilling Dot
tricks
import
confusion
tricks
comma Roc Co
C
underscore AUC underscore score
dot pipeline
import
pipeline
and from sqlan dot free
processing
import
polynomial
teachers
okay
okay there is Roc curve sorry
AP is capital
yeah
so now we will do some
basic like we will check AOC score for
the particular data set and we will
train and test the data using logistic
regression algorithm
okay
so
I will write here
X comma y equals to DF dot Loc
dear friends comma
point
friends
comma DIA
is
spot
okay
it's underscore train
comma X underscore test
comma y underscore train
comma y underscore test
question train
a test split
okay
then I will write here x comma y
comma test
size
0.2
comma random
it
equals to 42.
okay
logistic regression
was so linear
model
dot logistic
regression
see
equals to 1 e
minus five
years
question
polynomial
features
the Diggity
equals to 2
then model equals to pipeline
okay
polynomial
features
comma features
comma
we'll just take
regression
comma
so model equals to model dot fit
then underscore train
comma y underscore train
and
fpr
comma tpr
goes to Roc underscore go
then let's go test
comma margin
dot predict
probability
of X underscore test
then colon
comma one
PLT dot figure
then figure size should be
five
X
equals to
PLT
dot subplot
and comma 3 comma 1
X Dot Plot
to comma one
so comma one
comma
okay
okay
then ax Dot Plot
PR comma tpr
x dot set
title
AUC score
is
to
actually two decimals
okay dot format
Roc
let's go AUC underscore score
then y underscore test
comma model
dot predict
let's go probability
underscore test
one
so there is an error rank difference not
in index
create this line one
result
and
your TBR okay
too many values to enter
here you can see AUC score is 0.74 it's
quite good
okay so moving forward
we will import some
test
okay the idea is to like separate the
performance of each team as home or away
okay
so I will write here World Cup
rankings
let's go home
plus 2 y
underscore cup
rankings
for home
dot Group by
from Team
and same for the away team
Ginger
away
so like I will write y
Cup rankings
way
dot head
okay head should be 15 fine
yes
so here you can see
away team okay
Costa Rica sangal
with Team fever points
okay
team up with FIFA rank away team
total points
okay okay
got it why there is no awaiting
so
okay
okay
thank you
home team
it's working right
okay yeah so this is Argentina Australia
Belgium Brazil Cameron Canada and so on
the idea is to just separate the
performance of each team as a home or
away
okay
so
right here
objective wall
let's go World Cup
rankings
let's go away
Dot
index
yeah see Argentina already okay
so
now what we will do
we will do like number of simulations
like it has two
sort the teams in order to of peers they
might go against starting from round 16
till the finals
okay
till the finals so this is the very
large code so what I will do I will
write it for you quickly
okay
then I will get back to you
okay these are thousands is the number
of simulation I am doing repeating and
again and again
okay so it will take time
it will take time till then
till then we will write a code for like
power plot for the bar plot
okay
so for that I'm writing from
collections
import
counter
okay he's capital
and from matplotlib
Port figure
this is the every matches like single
USA it's like something like that okay
like Argentina one Brazil one Argentina
like this every match it will come so it
will take time
we go
so
right here
so for i n
list
underscore results
and results
equals to
counter
I
dot most
underscore command
X comma y
equals to zip
results
you go
ax
person
PLT
or subplots
then
figure size
should be
16 comma 8
x dot
bar right is X comma y
then ax dot set
y labels
is
schemes
so
so I will write here PLT dot show
the counter see
exact viable Steam
well it is not labels
yes
so here you can see the round six
and then quarter final and the
semi-final and the winner World Cup of
it's Belgium it's showing Belgium as per
the data and as per the logistic
regression so it is showing Belgium will
be the winner okay
okay let's see from the another graph
Port C bone
Suns
okay SNS dot set
let's go theme
I
was
quite great
Sinners dot set
figure size
because I should be 14
go on 10.
so we will here draw and we will draw a
nested bar plot by the team and the step
okay
we will draw this type of steps let's
see
g equals to SNS dot bar plot
data
equals to DF
underscore results
comma x equals to
deem
y equals to the probability
probability of winning
then Q equals to
tap
then
estimator
was to
sum
comma political two
question
dark
then
Alpha
equals to 0.6
okay
so let's see the graph final graph
figure size should be
Str is not callable
okay
figure dot figure size
as soon as bar plot
okay
right
it will work yeah
so as per you can see the round 16 is
purple
so Belgium is winning quarter final it's
like Belgium is top and the semi-final
it is still in the top and the final
Belgium is first and then Brazil
so as per
logistic regression and my analysis so
Belgium is winning
okay
so I hope you guys must have understood
how to predict FIFA World Cup winner
2000 2022 please comment down your below
your favorite team
okay so if you have any queries you can
ask in the comment section below our
team will respond you as soon as
possible and don't forget to check the
data sets from the description box below
and don't forget to comment down your
favorite team and if you want this full
code just type comment for the same
thank you so much for being here if you
enjoyed this video please subscribe to
our YouTube channel and give a like to
this video
till then keep learning and thank you
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here